[Music]
you
gulia cheeks CEO of Everly well welcome
to Stanford into the industrialist
dilemma thank you so much I'm so excited
to be here tell us a little bit about
the company and and what the company is
and the products that its delivers today
yes so I am the founder and CEO of
Everly well we're based in Austin we
have about 85 employees delivering about
50 million dollars of sales a year at
this point the business is four years
old and we have hundreds of thousands of
customers where we're changing their
lives with lab testing so I started the
company to solve a really simple problem
of creating a market for consumers to
get access to a variety of lab tests and
that has really grown into 35 different
lab tests across different categories
like sti's hormone testing
cardiovascular testing and the ability
to do it from home and have a guided
online results experience that actually
helps you solve your health problems so
we're changing lives every day and our
mission is really to be affordable and
accessible for everyone in America and
to change how you view lab testing is
part of your everyday health so what
created the opportunity for Everly well
to be started now versus maybe 10 or 15
years ago it's a great question because
I learned as an entrepreneur that I
think timing is so essential to success
and there were actually prior Everly
Wells who failed because I think they
were too early to market I really
believe that while I started the company
because I saw an opportunity with my
cohort or persona so women who had
unsolved health issues what I also saw
in the background was this drastically
shifting cost landscape in healthcare
and that the prices were still
astronomically high between service
providers and insurance companies but
insurance companies were covering less
and less and less so those bills were
increasingly ending up in the hands of
the average person and I didn't see that
changing anytime in the next decade so I
knew Everly well wouldn't actually work
if it was relying on the average
American to suddenly care about getting
their cholesterol tested I knew it would
work though if people were suddenly
paying with their own dollar not getting
the service that they expected or not
even knowing how much they were going to
have to pay at the end of the day and
that unfortunately is actually what
happened at a really rapid pace over the
last five years even faster than I
anticipated it so how do you think about
what are the next set of tests off or
how do you think about growing the
business and where you go from here so
we have a really interesting challenge
both creating the culture about really
well and how we think about our product
offering because we're bringing consumer
tech and health care together so in a
world where if you put a group of
doctors together and said hey what test
do you want to offer they would probably
say well we want to offer a CBC piano we
want a flu test things like that when
you put a group of consumers together
they generally if you put a Venn diagram
on a board those circles don't overlap
so we really start with where is the
largest consumer demand for a test where
can we offer that test more affordably
than through the traditional medical
system and then where is it accurate and
reliable because that has to be kind of
the foundational criteria there's some
tests we can't offer because using the
whole method just doesn't work yet but
if we can start with a really high
market demand list then we can start to
knock those off so for example we're
looking at allergy testing that's a
great market for us it's very overpriced
at something millions and millions of
people need access to we're looking at
additional heart health testing we're
looking at additional cancer screening
tests tests like that that we think are
becoming more and more common for a
consumer to want to pay for with things
as personal as one's health care ones
information how do you think about
privacy and security especially as a
start-up in such a critical and
important space this is I think our
policy on privacy and security our
position on it in the market that we've
been public about I think has actually
really differentiated us I took a stance
a few years ago that we would not sell
any data and I think that that has
served us well to enter that space
slowly given what is happening in the
public discourse around privacy both
with tech and then of course with things
like DNA companies so we have taken that
public stance which is how we kind of
decide principles of our business on who
we work with and you know we won't work
with pharma companies etc that being
said we also have to uphold that
internally we have to have the best
security practices and sometimes when
you're trying to build things quickly
and test them and you don't have a lot
of money and you're bootstrapping as an
entrepreneur those things are in tension
so I have found it really hard to think
about doing so
think cheap in healthcare and so I think
you know we've raised quite a bit of
money I think that's a direct reflection
of saying okay there's certain areas
where we can test and learn there's
other areas that we have higher
standards for table stakes than you
would normally have in like another
consumer app company so that's really
how we balance tit and we're one of the
few that is actually HIPAA compliant and
Medicare compliant because we work with
Humana so we have to do that very
carefully
how has the healthcare community
responded to what you're doing who has
been supportive who hasn't been
supportive and how are you navigating
that situation yes my take from when I
started the company to now I think that
the traditional medical community has
adopted the Everly well concept which I
would actually broaden to say consumer
directed health care that she then take
to your doctor and say hey I want you to
do something with this I think that
movement has changed with physicians
faster than I expected
the reason for that though again and
this is what we hear from doctors every
day is because of cost so when you get
an unexpected bill your patient calls
you and even if you didn't understand
that that's what they were going to get
built and so what we hear physicians
tell us is hey I love your testing
because I can say this vitamin D test is
$99 and not $600 through another lab and
so I think that is shifting where I do
think we have challenges is this virtual
model that I think all of primary care
will shift to and I think that will take
a number of years just given the
institution of traditional medicine to
shift us that way but it's already
happening so as you look at the business
going forward what do you think its
biggest challenges are over the next
five to ten years and what have been the
biggest challenges for you as a leader
coming into the healthcare space but
coming at it from an entrepreneurial
perspective and point of view I think it
healthcare at large and for our space in
the next decade I think you'll see a lot
of innovation around point of care
testing I think that can be good for
everly well if we stay ahead of the
innovation and if we partner with and do
deals with companies that are much more
biotech heavy that are actually
innovating on how do you collect blood
right how do you have a device that you
can read a result on your smartphone if
we don't do that I think we could be
disrupted are we ourselves as a
disruptor we'll be disrupted because
then we won't have you know a male a
male off kit is not
actually the ultimate innovation right
you want it in your home and to be able
to result right there
so I think that's a challenge we really
have to pay attention to for me as a
leader I never expected you know I never
even envisioned getting to a million
dollars in sales and so as we look at
the hundred million mark the two hundred
million mark profitability I think those
things are challenging me to step up
every day and say I'm now a professional
scaling CEO how do I be sure that I'm
getting myself out of a new job every
six months and leveling up my team and
that's a that requires self-discipline
and it requires a lot of self-reflection
and honesty with yourself about where
you need to fill your gaps
it's amazing four years in about how
you've had been able to have such a
impact on the healthcare business and
continuing to do so writing a lot of the
changes that are happening
Julie cheek CEO of Everly well thank you
so much for coming to Stanford thank you
for having me
[Music]